let me start by saying congratulations
on this movie thank you uh it's
fantastic I'm sure I'm joining the
chorus of people saying uh the same
thing so um a few questions for you uh
first let me start with um this is gonna
be my stupid one and it's gonna go for
you
um if Gwen and Kate Bishop were to meet
and actually get in a fight who do you
think wins it's not stupid I've thought
about it
um who do I think actually wins
wow you know so it seems as much as I
thought about it I don't know that I
have the answer I think they're both
highly highly capable uh and and skilled
I feel like between now and when it
happens right right of course
Kate will be more experienced right
she's she's they're both very quick but
do you know who what do you have um I
love Kate now I love Kate do you have an
opinion on you I I personally think Gwen
really yeah I think so too I think so
the spider sense is going to be the
thing like you're right you're not wrong
yeah all right yeah well I guess we'll
find out right well and you never
actually know
one of the things about the first film
are is the relationship between your two
characters and people loved it
um what can you tease in the sequel
about their relationship and what's
going on
it's on you oh yeah uh well what can I
what an idea is uh it's definitely
evolved their relationship has
definitely evolved
um they are going through
a very similar part of life in this and
they really have each other as they
always have to lean on and to uh confide
in
um
yeah they're they're they're facing some
wild responsibilities this time around
so some hurdles yep some some challenges
but their relationship definitely I feel
is they're already connected you know
but I think as they face these
challenges it it really strengthens each
nook and cranny as they get through it
because when they get through it they'll
really know they can count on each other
in an entirely different way so what I
learned after watching this film is
these titles are very literal the first
one is into the spider-verse this is
across the spider verse the third one is
beyond the spider verse and when I think
beyond the spider verse I start thinking
is there any chance they're going to do
like a small live action bit because
it's not
in the spider-verse so I'm just looking
at the two of you and wondering is there
any chance you will play a live action
version of your character I mean you saw
the segment right I have seen the second
one yeah I mean
um I don't know I guess we'll see I'll
be honest though I didn't really thought
of that before you said it and that's a
great I like that I mean but they're
very literal they are I didn't
understand it until I saw the second
movie okay and the second movie is
across the spider verse right so beyond
can only mean one thing
I start listening this is just where I
have to ask you guys
um I hope you ask them and oh I haven't
and you're like oh I hope I hope you
guys at home
make sure if they do
you know
I'm just about out of time I really do
hope it happens because I think it would
be epic awesome
um what do you think would surprise fans
of spider-verse to learn about the
actual like voice recording and the
making of it from your perspective
um you know honestly I learned every day
I learned I learned uh
me personally in my life as I was as I
was saying a lot of these lines and
taking in the message of it I feel like
I've been able to apply it I've learned
that Miles has some real heart he has
courage I've learned that um that while
we become confident we're we still we're
learning every day and we can learn from
everybody and it's easy to want
validation from people we look up to or
our lovers or the people we respect the
most but it's about
um having that self validation and
finding your moral compass and following
your gut and figuring out how you want
to wear that mask I feel like that's
what I learned about recording it that's
what I learned about watching it and I
hope that's what they the audience
learns wow or feels while doing the same
yeah I mean this this whole process is
wild and it's unlike anything I've ever
experienced I think I I may have had
some misconceptions of voice acting uh
before really diving into this and I
think having the chance to go back and
do it a second time understanding the
process this time around there was a
newfound confidence and having had the
time to live with this character on the
first film coming back in and and really
uh
knowing how to use the space this time
around I think people don't uh again I
didn't understand what it what it meant
or what it looked like and and it's uh
it's it's exciting so I'm hoping that
everything that we did in that room
translates to the screen and and um
Beyond yeah uh thank you so much gotta
go gonna be huge